-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy Award-winning actor
you know from films
such as "Inception," "Snowden,"
and "The Trial
of the Chicago 7."
He created, directed,
and stars in "Mr. Corman."
New episodes are released
Fridays on Apple TV+.
Let's take a look.
-I love Costco hummus.
-Josh.
-What?
[ Chuckling ] I do.
[ Video-game gunfire ]
Do you see how much time
they let him have on that thing?
It's not okay.
You see his eyes?
It's scary.
-You played just as many video
games when you were his age.
I mean, for hours, you would sit
in front of that screen.
And you turned out fine.
-Did I?
-Are you done?
-What? I'm just
concerned for him.
-No, you are
not concerned for him.
-What makes you say that?
-You've always had something
against David.
-I don't have anything
He's just a bad person.
-He's 7!
-Yeah, but you can be
a bad person when you're 7.
Doesn't mean
you'll stay a bad person.
-Please welcome back to the show
Joseph Gordon-Levitt.
How are you, Joseph?
-Hello. I'm well.
Good to see you, Seth.
-Thank you for joining us
from halfway around the world.
You're in New Zealand right now,
and you have been
for a better part of this year.
-Yeah. Very grateful to be here.
I feel like I won the lottery
getting to be here
in New Zealand.
If you don't know,
they handled the virus here.
It's a huge testament
to the people of this country.
They're team players, the Kiwis.
-I have heard from a few people
who've been lucky enough
to be there,
and that seems to be the report.
I know you have young kids
with you, as well.
Are they enjoying it?
-Oh, yeah. I mean, I get to take
my boy to school every day.
Like I said, it's so,
so lucky to be here.
You know, my work
got to bring me here,
and my whole family
is just grateful every day.
-So, this is a really cool show.
You created it, directed,
star in it,
and very personal as well.
What was the sort of beginnings
of this idea?
-Well, so, "Mr. Corman,"
it's about a person
who has a lot to be grateful for
and, you know,
who's doing his best to be happy
but just isn't happy
all the time.
And, you know,
in the second episode,
he has a full-blown
anxiety attack.
So it's a lighthearted comedy.
And, you know, there's --
There's a lot of talk nowadays
about mental health,
which I think is really a good
thing.
There's historically
been a stigma.
People going through anxiety
don't want to talk about it,
'cause they think
people will say,
"Hey, you know, suck it up.
Quit whining," et cetera.
But the truth is, like
one out of every six Americans
has some kind
of anxiety disorder.
And I think it's great
and it's time
for all of us to be there
for each other
and not telling people, like,
"Hey, just quit whining."
But we're here and, you know,
offer our kindness.
-You know, it's interesting,
'cause I think you're right,
that it is destigmatized
a great deal
compared to maybe 10 years ago.
But then you also see
what Simone Biles
and Naomi Osaka go through
where I feel like
there's great amount of empathy
from some people
and then a lack of understanding
and compassion on others.
Do you feel like
when you lay out a full story
like you're given
the time to do,
as opposed to when
we just see, you know,
people talk about mental health
in small snapshots,
is the idea here that you'll
give people a better sense
of what that journey is like
when they're dealing
with depression?
-I love that question.
Yeah, 'cause this is
10 episodes, right?
So at the beginning, he's --
He is really struggling.
By the end, I think he's made
some really important progress.
And that can be so uplifting
when you've lived through it for
quite a while with a character
over these 10
half-hour episodes.
-Another personal element
of this is I read
you based it on a couple friends
of yours growing up.
Is this something
that they were excited about,
or did you even
tell them the news?
-Oh, I told them. Yeah. A couple
of my friends are in it.
You know, these are guys
that aren't actors,
just guys I went to high school
with
but I managed to, like,
find little parts for them.
And yeah, the part
that Arturo Castro plays,
who's a brilliant actor,
was sort of inspired
by my friend Hector
who I went to high school with
and who actually, you know,
does work at UPS.
And we got Hector
into the pilot. He's in there.
Hector Hernandez, rocking it.
He was amazing
in "A Funny Thing Happened
On The Way To The Forum"
at Van Nuys High
when we were seniors,
and now, he's, you know,
on a show on Apple.
-Was he --
Did he have any nerves about it,
or did he know
he had it well under control?
-Oh, hell yeah,
he was very nervous.
[ Laughing ] The whole time.
But I was like,
"Dude, you're going to be
totally, totally good."
And we got it, man.
And he's totally keeping up with
like all the other four of us
who are, you know,
people who do this for a living.
And but he nailed it.
He's great in it.
-There are, of course,
no small parts,
only small actors.
And you have taken this
to heart,
because, so, Rian Johnson
is a fantastic director
who you worked with a lot
as sort of the lead
in films of his.
I did not realize that you have
also found your way
into every one of his projects
over the years,
from "Knives Out"
to the "Star Wars" films.
-It's, yeah, we have a streak
going I hope we never break.
And yes, if I don't get
to be in one of his movies,
he gets me to do
these little cameos.
I got to do a creature voice
in "The Last Jedi,"
and I got to do
the voice of, you know,
the sort of cheesy crime drama
that the protagonist
happens to be watching,
and I'm in the background
going like,
"You can't handle the truth!"
or whatever it was that I said.
-It's very nice
to have a relationship
with a director like that that
can survive over multiple films.
-I'm very lucky, yeah.
Rian's amazing. It's true.
-You play a fifth grade teacher
in this show.
A lot of people always ask me,
"If you weren't doing
what you're doing,
what job would you want?"
I've always sort of thought
teacher might be a path.
I'm lucky enough to be the son
of a public school teacher.
What was --
Is teaching something
that you could have
seen yourself doing?
-Okay, well, first of all, is it
your mom or dad who's a teacher?
-My mom.
-Okay. So round of applause
for your mom
and huge, huge respect.
I think teachers are heroes.
And I've always had
this same feeling
that I've wanted to be a teacher
and would love to do that
at some point in my life.
That's why I wrote this
character to be a teacher.
If I could wave a magic wand,
I would have us live in a world
where teachers were the ones
that we were all celebrating,
and we were all chatting
on social media
about, like, "Oh, did you see
that new curriculum
from that one teacher?
It's so amazing!"
Like, we would live
in such a better place
if teachers were all making
hundreds of thousands
or millions of dollars a year.
I think
that should be the new rule.
I think like the bottom salary,
yearly salary,
for a teacher
should be quarter mil.
And then everyone,
the best and the brightest
would competing
for teacher jobs.
Like, that would be way better
than people competing
for acting jobs.
[ Laughing ] What do actors
really offer the world?
-Plus, I mean, I think people
don't quite realize
how lucky you are if you have
a parent who's a teacher,
because they have access
to a laminator.
And...
-Mm.
-You know, that's a giant
piece of equipment.
Like, no one has a laminator
in their home.
But you get someone in a public
school system, they can go in,
and they could laminate
that comic book for you.
-How big a thing
can you laminate,
like just a standard paper?
Can you, like, laminate
a bigger --
-I feel like I use --
You can go bigger than --
I felt like I laminated a lot of
covers of "Sports Illustrated."
That was like a thing that
I would do growing up, so...
-'Cause what I would want to do
would be laminate the biggest
thing I could possibly laminate,
because what I love
about laminated things
is you can like [Warbling]
They make that sound
when you shake them.
You know what I mean?
-You're right. You have a far --
You have a better vision
for that opportunity than I had.
I'm already looking back
and regretting my past.
[ Both laugh ]
Hey, congratulations
on the show.
Thanks for making time
for us today.
It's always great to see you.
-So good to see you, man.
Thank you.
-Be well.
New episodes of "Mr. Corman" are
released Fridays on Apple TV+.